hey so today i'll show you how to add a
3d model to a website using 3gs
now one of the most compelling reasons
to use 3js and 3d javascript in general
is that it's a marriage of the power and
flexibility of the open web
combined with cutting-edge graphical
features something that's difficult or
even outright impossible to build using
some other platform like
unity can be pretty straightforward in
javascript and html
so for this tutorial we'll be using 3js
which
if you're watching for the first time is
a great javascript 3d library for
wrapping webgl
we've already covered basic setup and
initialization in a previous tutorial so
definitely check those out for more
information
and we've also covered model loading the
reason i mention this is because
i'll kind of gloss over those parts
pretty quickly
since it's covered by other tutorials
anyway we'll start with the same
initialization code as the first project
i'll just go over quickly what this does
as you can see here we instantiate 3js
create a camera and a few lights nothing
that wasn't already covered previously
if i were to run this as is we'd just
see an empty plane sitting on a black
background
now we'll start integrating the 3d onto
the page starting with just
adding a simple 3d model to the website
using the gltf loader
what i'm going to do is head over to my
favorite 3d model site sketchfab
and we'll search for something decent to
show i was watching that new picard show
recently so i've kind of got star trek
on the brain
let's grab a nice model of the
enterprise just a quick couple of lines
should load this
we just need to instantiate a loader set
the path
and now we go and load that up in the
browser exactly what we expected to see
the enterprise to integrate this onto
the web page is pretty easy
3js just operates on the canvas element
on the page itself
if you check dev tools here you can see
the structure of the page and see that
it's a dom element that's being rendered
to
this is an important point the canvas
that 3gs uses just
another element in the dom tree another
element on the page like text
or images so for example if i were to
create a small web page
let's go and create a really quick one
we'll just make a title section here and
some text and images below
in the title section i'm going to put
some text and then on the right we'll
have a square space that will fill in
with a 3d model
this is all just kind of fake garbage in
reality this can be structured any way
you like but this is just
an example anyway here's what i ended up
with i've got this title section and a
bunch of garbage text and images below
looks kind of like a real website so now
i go back into the initialization code
here and instead of appending the new
canvas element to the body
we use get element by id and append the
canvas element in another place in the
dom tree
when we load this up we've got the model
showing up here in this little window
instead
pretty neat so here's a slight catch if
let's say i add background color to this
page or even a background image
this little model shows up with a black
background we can get it to integrate
more seamlessly by changing the
initialization parameters a bit
if you look at the docs for webgl
renderer you'll notice that there's an
alpha parameter that defaults to false
tweaking this and setting it to true so
we'll modify the code here and set this
to true
now loading this in the browser yields a
model that now blends on top of whatever
was in the background of the page
the last thing is that we can listen for
events on the page and add a bit of
interactivity either passively or
actively
let's modify the code a bit to animate
when the user scrolls the page
so in the code here we'll make the 3gs
canvas part of the header
and we'll make it a sticky header so as
you scroll the page it stays at the top
that's pretty easy with a few small css
changes
the next changes will define an event
handler using window.add
window.addeventlistener for the scroll
event
there's some good documentation here on
the mozilla site
but essentially we just want to listen
for input events and respond by
notifying the 3js app
we'll do that by calling app.onscroll
with the position of the scroll bar
now you can do anything in here for
example we can blend between two
different camera positions for two
different scenes
so what i've done here is i've defined
two different scenes at two different
positions and will linearly
interpolate between the two scenes using
the normalized scroll position
now when we scroll the page the 3d scene
sticks to the top but animates based on
the page scroll position
and of course you can go a lot further
you can look at the mouse position you
can
rotate things you can do whatever you
want really it doesn't matter that about
covers the basics of embedding 3d on a
website using
3js hope you all enjoyed this remember
to like and subscribe and of course let
me know if you have any suggestions on
future tutorials or areas that you'd
like to see explored
more in depth and i'll add them to my
roadmap
like always code is available on github
grab it fork it
do whatever you want it's yours to play
with and i'll see you next time
cheers